olivia munn is officially a mom the
x-men actress has given birth to a baby
boy with john mullaney and the happy
news has been under wraps the duo
reportedly became first-time parents on
november 24th exciting john broke the
news that they were expecting back in
september during an appearance on late
night with seth meyers i packed a lot
into this is it september now it is uh
it is september yeah then in the spring
i went to los angeles and uh uh
met and started to date the wonderful
woman named olivia and we're having a
baby together it was i was nervous when
i was about to say the news
that's why i looked down and then i
looked up yeah no like it wasn't that
you like forgot it or anything no no no
it's really thrilling i'm gonna be a dad
yeah it's gonna be amazing
congratulations thank you i'm really
really we're both really really happy
shortly after olivia sneakily debuted
her baby bump on instagram the new mama
posted this video and fans couldn't help
noticing her tiny belly i want to start
off by saying congratulations i know
you're expecting a baby how's it going
i'm exhausted a lot
tired um but it's going really good and
in october the newsroom alum made her
own late night appearance opening up
about the confusing baby advice that
she'd been getting there's this one item
called the snoo
that people bring up a lot
and then i'm not and i'm not quite sure
like i know it's one that rocks the baby
then there's like a one that docks the
baby and then there's another one that
like props the baby
and they're all like you're right
they're all named the same thing and i
have no idea what anyone's i'm trying to
research it i actually have the thing i
have the hardest problem with is
um i don't know how many things to get
you know like i don't know how many
onesies you're supposed to get i don't
know how many
uh bottles you're supposed to get how
many diapers are you supposed to have
like i don't people give me a lot of
advice but i don't i need real specifics
et also chatted with the actress that
month here's what she told us she was
most looking forward to about becoming a
mom honestly i'm just excited about
um
meeting whoever it is and bringing a
little person into this world olivia and
john first sparked relationship rumors
back in may shortly after e.t confirmed
that the former saturday night live
writer had split from wife anna marie
tendler after six years of marriage
following his exit from a 60-day rehab
program cut to october john and olivia's
names actually trended on social media
after breakup rumors surfaced thanks to
gossip account dumois but as e.t
previously learned at the time those
rumors were not true i mean i don't have
kids i can't i mean honestly it's a lot
to imagine you know in 2019 olivia told
e.t this about her outlook on kids and
marriage at the time she was dating
philadelphia fusion president tucker
roberts i'm already
in my happily ever after and that's you
know and if i want to have kids or want
to get married then you know i'll do
that but it has to add to my life i've
already loved my life as it is but it's
um i've already reached the pinnacle for
me which what i think happiness should
look like oh how things have changed
congratulations to the first time
parents well i appreciate that thank you
very much